deux voies dans le spectre de la
politique canadienne justin trudeau qui
fera campagne contre le populisme de
lors de ces élections et l autre goubin
maxime bernier qu'il n'y a pas de
problème à assumer cette étiquette de
populiste et on est à huit semaines des
élections fédérales
alors les canadiens sont-ils sensibles à
un vent de populisme et bien un sondage
la mesure et on a les résultats ce soir
et nous recevons le chercheur principal
de ce projet qui s'appelle renforcer la
démocratie canadienne daniel savas du
centre gauche des bosses que pour le
dialogue de l'université simon fraser un
ancien aussi de chez ipsos bonsoir
monsieur savas bienvenu 24 60
bonsoir et jean marc léger président de
la firme de sondage léger les qui sonde
régulièrement nos coeurs d'oxydé bonsoir
jean marc
j'ai commencé avec vous monsieur savas
brièvement votre démarche pourquoi
sonder les canadiens koala
d'échantillonnage de 3500 personnes sur
ses préoccupations quant au populisme et
si je donne un chiffre 68 % des
canadiens ont le sentiment que les élus
ne se soucie pas de ce que pensent des
gens comme eux potez on a lancé un
projet qui s'appelait renforcer la
démocratie canadienne il y a deux ans et
on s'inquiétait beaucoup sur le déclin
de la préférence pour la démocratie
depuis 2012 a donc on voulait vraiment
tenté de pouls de la population
canadienne en ce moment pour voir
jusqu'à quel point on serait prête à
accepter le changement vers le populisme
en eau
dans le contexte global est donc la
principale conclusion quand vous
regardez donc la première conclusion que
moi je tiendrai de ces résultats c'est
que oui les canadiens et canadiennes
sont sont attirés par un certain message
populiste dont autres le message qui va
mettre les gens ordinaires contre
l'élite a aussi incertaine appel aux
discours nativistes saveur nationaliste
la majorité des gens au canada quoique
ils voteraient pour un candidat qui
prônerait ce genre de discours à quoi
par contre là on n'est pas prête à aller
jusqu'à accepter les discours qui
attaquent les médias ni qui va critiquer
concrètement le gouvernement
c'est-à-dire de régimes démocratiques en
vue là on soutient la démocratie jean
marc léger c'est quel résultat vous a
frappé le plus c'est une bonne étude sa
masse réseau de daniels une bonne étude
qui permet de mesurer la montée du
populisme pas nécessairement les
intentions de vote encore milieu de mon
tequila qui est partout dans l'accident
la montée en europe aux élections
européennes les partis d'extrême droite
ont gagné des votes
aux etats unis également le populaire a
été récupéré par la droite à travers le
monde en europe et de bons exemples
son art au brésil est un bon exemple
mais on a mis boris johnson à uk en
bretagne des exemples partout dans le
monde une montée très très forte du
populisme on mesure ici nous dans nos
sondages on a aussi d'autres questions
sur ce que 80 pour cent des canadiens
estiment que les politiciens mentent
parce que derrière le popu les six à
trois facteurs de base
je la barre une crise de confiance dans
le système l'équipe canadienne micro
appuyer des données même déçu sans une
fraser sur deux dans le fond disent que
la démocratie ne fonctionne pas et donc
il ya vraiment une montée de crise de
confiance est aussi derrière cette crise
identitaire
c'était l'arrivée des migrants en europe
par exemple où la bataille osthouse 10 4
ans porte sur des immigrants qui est le
deuxième facteur derrière ça est ce que
ça donne c'est 3 des facteurs c'est
l'obsession sécuritaire
trois facteurs qui ce qui
s'entrecroisent il y crée cette montée
l'eau du populisme partout dans le monde
et on commence à la voir au canada
paul est un bon exemple en ontario il a
été élu si on pense que ça touche pas la
nature
indienne c'est pas vrai le yahia on voit
poindre le populisme canada est le
chiffre qui peut être intéressant aussi
monsieur ça va se soucier de ce que jean
marc indien vous disiez tout à l'heure
c'est que 80 % des canadiens et
canadiennes se tiendrait probablement
candidat qui défend les gens ordinaires
contre l'élite on croirait entendre dont
les gens kong
on a des candidats pour le vraiment noms
des candidats qui ont des belles valeurs
la classe moyenne c'est un peu ça qui se
cache derrière ce chiffre monsieur savas
pour moi je ne suis pas tellement
surpris par ce résultat parce que c'est
un discours que prendre les candidats
aux élections depuis longtemps au rang
de la classe moyenne où on veut vraiment
toucher les gens ordinaires pour moi je
ne suis pas surpris par ces résultats
et pour vous jean-marc gamin quand on
regarde les résultats d'un str quant à
maxime bernier par exemple à l'échelle
nationale c'est pas probants il était
mon pauvre non mais ce n'est pas tout
parce qu'une montée du populisme qu'un
politicien qui veut être populiste va
rechercher des appuis back cette
dernière 4 % dans les sondages c'est ce
qu'il avait durci moi c'est ce qu il
encore aujourd'hui a pas de montée du
parti populaire au canada une montée par
contre au niveau du parti conservateur
un discours un peu plus populiste qui
sont un peu de droit particulier dans
l'ouest canadien qui est incarné par
jason kenny en alberta la v7 montella
qui existent mais les canadiens sont
beaucoup plus tolérants aux états unis
par exemple cette moto est important
donald trump est un discours at 6
milliards à tous les jours encore
toujours en 41 43 pour cent d'appuis il
ya près d'un sur deux aux états unis qui
appuient ce type de discours mais le
message que ça envoie si on est on est
prêt à soutenir des candidats qui est
défendre les gens ordinaires contre les
lettons dont identifie la classe
politique à l'élite des jeunes rage dans
les lecteurs une rage contre le système
politique une rage contre les élites une
rage contre les médiaux également sur un
planisphère de fake news bien car une
partie de la population
une rage qui s'exprime par par le
populiste il est surtout de droite
il est aussi un peu de gauche parce
qu'on associe pas pu laisser droite ma
réalité il ya des partis dans le monde
le pot d'homos en espagne ou en grèce le
principal parti également de gauche il
ya une incarnation de ce point de vue
les stades et des deux côtés mais ici au
canada
on le voit poindre il est là au niveau
provincial et il va faire partie de la
campagne
notamment la question des migrations et
l'éléphant dans la pièce dans la
campagne électorale j'ai vu maxime
bernier son panneau la whey fini à
l'immigration de masse ou matfer les
migrations de masse
il est directement dans le sujet il
décède en fond de capter sur votre
logement
les conclusions je peux rivaliser
monsieur savard oui il faut pas
confondre le populisme avec un sentiment
anti démocratique au canada
ça c'est quelque chose de veiller à ce
que la plus grande partie de la
population qui a un lien trois quarts de
la population canadienne préfère la
démocratie et sa augmentés depuis 2 ans
de 2 points donc il faut se faire
rassurant parce qu'on voit c'est la
question l'existence même si on n'est
pas très contents de la façon dont la
démocratie marche en ce moment on n'est
pas prête à aimer jusqu'à appuie un
populisme telle qu'on voit aux états
unis en tête dans l'est de l'europe
oui parce que trump aux états unis
attaquent les instances judiciaires et
sans faire à son profit vous qu'est-ce
qui s'insurgent elles avaient dit que la
démocratie est le moins pire des
systèmes ouais mais il est vraiment une
contestation qui très forte qui l'attend
la personne de l'incarnent véritablement
au canada personne n'est donald trump au
canada très personnelle d'un câble
mais s'il fallait qu'un politicien fort
par elles prennent le leadership là
dessus il y aurait un potentiel
l'élection qu'on voit c'est une élection
qui va être très difficile parce qu'au
moment où on se parle dans le dernier
sondage seulement 35 % des canadiens ont
fixé leur choix
les deux tiers ne savent pas encore pour
qui vont voter millions d'intentions
mais ça peut changer d'idée c'est du
jamais vu sur les lecteurs et orphelins
est ce que ça crée dans le fond c'est
une campagne qui risque d'être salle o2
tous les partis politiques le président
camara rice avait toutefois pas être
prêt vrai dur alors première tranche de
ces sondages sur une autre période à
venir monsieur savas quelle est la suite
pour vous l'intention derrière ces
résultats là comment s'en servir a qui
vont être vont-ils être utile je pense
que ça va être très utile pour les
partis politiques parce que d'abord on
voit que les canadiens ne sont pas
satisfaits d'eux
du fait que leur vote ne compte pas on
n'a pas l'impression qu'on peut vraiment
influencer les décisions
gouvernementales
évidemment on ne croit pas que les aides
les élus vraiment pense sérieusement à
ce que les gens parler les gens disent
donc pour les pour les lits pour les
candidats il faut vraiment trouver les
moyens pour toucher les intérêts
vraiment important des canadiens et
canadiennes en ce moment les canadiens
passent les canadiens canadiennes ne
sont pas convaincus que les élus
tiennent compte les intérêts en effet
remercie jean bad pour vous le mot de la
fin
monde à faire les problèmes sont de plus
en plus complexes si les populistes ont
des solutions de plus en plus simple des
réponses quelque part avec l'été ça va
éclater merci beaucoup monsieur savas
depuis la colombie britannique jean marc
léger toujours un plaisir de vous
recevoir sa lettre
on vous souhaite une bonne campagne